[Music]
welcome back
to the machine learning street talk
youtube channel and podcast
so today we have an incredibly special
guest professor carl fristan
it was one of the most fascinating
conversations we've ever had on street
talk
this is an old school professor he went
to cambridge in 1980 and
he's one of these kind of um eccentric
polymath
types that you know sits on the the old
kind of
chesterfield chair with all of the
springs coming out and you know
smoking a pipe or something like that
professor fristen is most well known
certainly in the machine learning domain
for his
free energy principle or active
inference which is a kind of
reinforcement learning
flavor of that if you like but he's got
an incredible
background he is an expert in psychiatry
and cognitive neuroscience and
physics and bayesian statistics it's so
strange just to have
all of this knowledge embodied in one
person
so it really was quite an interesting
conversation actually
now the free energy principle has been
called a postulate a natural law
an imperative an unfalsifiable principle
it's been called many things it aims to
give an almost
universal understanding between the mind
life and the environment so how did the
free energy principle come about
the free energy principle as you have
just described it
started really when i was a student
aspiring
to put together maths and psychologies
and gets back to
mathematical formalisms the you know the
principles that underlie
the sentient behavior with which we are
gifted and the product of that
was the free energy principle the free
energy principle sets the foundation
for planning as inference by explicitly
modeling the world and its states
as beliefs it balances accuracy with
entropy
which maintains the flexibility needed
to continually adapt
to future outcomes and explorations but
the more interesting game
is i think better cast in terms of
planning
as inference enabling you to roll out
much further into the future and ask
well what would happen if i did that
what would my beliefs
be about the state of the world in the
long term future
so i think prediction in its full and
glorious anticipatory
sense really takes center stage features
of reality itself such as
self-organized behavior and even quantum
they seem to require some kind of
probabilistic
bayesian belief update on world states
for example the path integration
formalism from richard feynman
it essentially averages over many
probabilistically weighted paths
in other words functions over beliefs
and has proven crucial
to the subsequent development of quantum
electrodynamics
that's what happened to understand
the first principles underlie sentient
behavior
you have to understand the dynamics of
self-organization in particular
self-organization of systems that are
open
to the environment that comes in through
fyman's path integral formulation and
thinking not just about
the flow of the dynamics of
self-organization
at this point in time but trajectories
into the future
and the probability distributions over
those trajectories and particularly
the states that act upon the outside
and then things get much more
interesting you can interpret this
in terms of inferring the most likely
paths
basically as resting upon a prediction
of states of the world
in the future conditioned upon a
particular sequence of actions
or policy the heart of the free energy
principle
and what sets it apart from alternatives
is the strict balance between
accuracy and simplicity evidence
and entropy one of the things that i
think is very interesting about the
free energy formulation is that
prediction is half the story
so getting accurate predictions about
the future while
very important is juxtaposed
with keeping your options open keeping a
flexible mind
keeping a high entropy model of the
world so that as you encounter perhaps
new situations it has the flexibility to
adapt
in the central role of relative
entropies in this sort of variational
construct
i think that your formerly that is so
important
in minimizing the free energy you're
also trying to maximize the entropy it
seems sometimes
counterintuitive but it is exactly that
which is really mandated by things like
occam's principle
and very practically relevant so if you
don't do that
if you don't put that uncertainty into
the games then you're going to run into
things like sharp minima and you're
going to be searching for
resolutions of that in terms of
broadening your uncertainty
flattening that free energy landscape
just to try and secure those
flat minima where you can be more
reasonably assured that you've got some
global minima
say in standard deep learning or a
machine learning context
so this led fristen to believe that
goal-directed behavior
essentially planning based on goals is
insufficient
we need to have a more sophisticated
system that can
reason about the uncertainty of our
beliefs we see echoes of this in machine
learning we spoke to kenneth stanley
recently about novelty search
and in his formalism he explicitly
avoids objectives and he
thinks that we should use novelty
because of the inherent deception
in objective search similarly in classic
machine learning we use regularization
to stop the machine learning algorithm
overfitting
the training set fristen argues that the
free energy principle combines
all of these different paradigms we're
getting quite close to the center of the
bullseye here
and we're talking about the dichotomy
between belief-free
and belief-based methods you know you
said in your papers that
goal-directed behaviors is fine for
learning kind of basic habitual policies
of course normally there's this value
function that needs to be either
computed directly in the non-stochastic
setting using the bellman equations or
or some other method but
but your approach is a stark departure
away from having this value function
again you've said everything that i
could possibly say so
i'll send you on my next lecture tour
that'll take the pressure off me yeah
absolutely and of course i forgot to
just to highlight this sort of
exploitation exploration dilemma that
has done
20th century thinking minimizing this
mixture that just
is the the expected free energy you
you've got expiration and exploitation
sold for free in the right order so you
normally
see this food in the fridge before you
start preparing your meal you don't do
it the other way around
and but you said it you said that the
bellman authority principle is only fit
for purpose
if there exists a value function of
states that will ensue
if i connect to that action let's talk
about markov blankets
markov blankets are probably the one
piece of jargon which you're going to
hear today more than any other
term we have an innate common sense
notion of
things and the boundaries that separate
them
however capturing this mathematically is
more difficult than we might expect the
markov blanket concept formalizes these
notions
and underpins the free energy principle
one of the pivotal concepts in the
free energy principle is markov blankets
tell us about them they're relatively
straightforward if you imagine
um here on our screen we're showing an
image and if every single one of these
little disks that you see there was a
state and if you have a system that can
be
partitioned then the red dots that are
in the middle
are the thing itself the blue dots that
are outside
are the universe at large the external
environment
and the yellow and orange dots in
between
form the marcotte blanket and what the
markov blanket requirements are
is that the red is able to interact
with orange okay orange is able to
interact with yellow and yellow is able
to interact
with the blue but what we don't have is
we don't have
blue being directly affected and vice
versa by
by red so we don't have this so instead
we have this
these boundary sets we partitioned
all the state space into an internal
group the red ones
an external group the blue in these
blanket states that sit in between the
two
and facilitate the interaction between
external
and internal and why these are important
for the free energy principle
is they set up these conditional
independencies which say that the
blue states as long as i know
yellow and orange they're independent
informationally from the red states
and likewise the red states so long as i
know
the blanket states are independent of
the external ones
and yet future conceptions might rely on
even more general concepts
that allow for markov blankets like for
example wandering sets
i'd like to explore that as you put it
maliciously engineered
false dichotomy a little bit further but
in a different context and someone of
the
marcotte blanket for example you were
with uh sean carroll
uh long ago and i think he asked does a
hurricane have a markov blanket and
he said well no it doesn't and that's
that's quite annoying actually
if it's enough of a boundary enough of a
blanket
if you will i can still think about in
useful ways
is that true i mean do we really need an
exact markov blanket or is it flexible
enough that it can be quite a fuzzy
boundary
there's an excellent question and the
honest answer is i i don't really know
at this stage
but what is known uh and in not knowing
that i mean that in a positive way that
this is a future challenge i think
people will contend with
in the next few years so in an idealized
formulation the markov blanket
exists at non-equilibrium steady state
so it exists in eternity
in a very crisp and well-defined way
that there are specific
conditional independences that allow for
a vicarious coupling between the inside
and the outside
so it's the device that gets you out of
20th century equilibrium physics that
we're not talking about
closed systems anymore we're talking
about uh non-equilibrium steady states
so
we're really in the sort of the things
that people like sean carroll a lot of
other people
are contending with at the moment the
physics of open systems and
self-organizing systems
and a markup plan kit plays a incredible
incredibly crucial role here
in demarcating the edge of the system as
it were
that allows you to identify something
stuff on the inside the markov blanket
has to have a kind of synchrony
with stuff on the outside and in virtue
of those conditional dependencies that
stipulatively define the markov blanket
you can now treat the internal states as
parameterizing
probability distributions or belief
distributions about
external states so there's quite a
fundamental
bit of information geometry that you
bring to the table
when you have a markov blanket that
suddenly you can interpret
the machinations on the inside in your
computer
or your variation auto encoder or your
brain
as having beliefs of a bayesian sword
about what caused these data what's
going on the outside so the markup
blanket is absolutely central
everything inherits from the markov
blanket so to move on to your more
challenging question
does a hurricane or the eternal flame
have a mark of black and strictly
speaking no it doesn't
because you've got this fuzzy leaking it
is
from the point of view somebody's wanted
to simplify things as a physicist
very irritating but of course it's all
also incredibly important and
challenging
so where would you go to try and
understand
these fluctuating blankets where you
have exchanges and i worry about this
every time i cut my fingernails
or have my hair cut at what point did my
mark or blanket become
an external state so there's clearly
there's clearly a bit of
work to be done mathematically to
accommodate
markov blankets as themselves
dynamically random objects
my guess is that you're going to
probably go back to the work of
irkov who was this one of the key
intellectual architects
of ergot history in ergolic theory and
he
was at one point occupied by the notion
of wandering sets so if we think of the
markov blanket as a partition
of all the states of the universe into
lots and lots of particles that comprise
the internal states and their mark of
blankets
and if you consider that partition into
particles
as a partitioning into subsets and then
you bring
wandering sets into play you can now
start to see
a mechanics and a mathematics where you
can now actually
explain things like hurricanes and
candles
3d printers printing themselves is a
species of 3d printers
one big mark of blanket or do i drill
down and just say markup that only
really exists
for the lifetime of the 3d printer so
all of these issues i think speak to
exactly what you're drilling down on
which is how can you
accommodate fluctuations and
if you like physics of non-equilibria
not of states of a universe but of the
blanket or the partitions that define
the other markov blankets does the free
energy principle conform to itself
if we can imagine into the future maybe
and if in the spirit of
the free energy principle we maintain
uncertainty about the free energy
principle
yeah that's very clever yes yeah so
i often say in moments of vanity and
pride that the free energy
principle is one of the very few
principles that conforms to itself
it's trying to provide an accurate but
minimally complex explanation for
everything
and the only other thing that i know
that conforms to itself
is the principle of natural selection in
the sense that the theories of natural
selection themselves evolved
from perry and third world and in that
sense this notion that the free energy
principle should accommodate
a judicious amount of uncertainty about
itself is absolutely right yeah
that's a great very clever observation
fristen would argue that certain states
of the world and certain states of
knowledge
would kind of transform themselves
conforming to probability
theory the free energy principle implies
that non-equilibrium steady-state
systems
must directly model such states of
knowledge and maintain them
according to the rules of probable
inference in order to continue existing
in other words survival fitness requires
inference we had this very interesting
point from conor about
there may be game theoretic pressures
let's say to drive down accuracy in
in some sense the free energy principle
is a lot about
the idea of we want to gain information
to create a better more accurate model
of the world around us
but there are situations in game theory
and decision theory where that's
actually not
fitness enhancing you might not want to
learn the
face of your kidnapper because he's more
likely to kill you
yeah that's a fascinating area and i i
see those those sort of themes
in many different contexts i never heard
that before about not
wanting to know the face of your
kidnapper but that's a
beautiful example it really does tell
you that objective functions have to be
about beliefs and the consequences of
belief states
not states of the world so if there's
one example that tells you you're not
going to serve up with the bellman
optimality principle
that's going to be it but it also tells
you
that many of these real world problems
have to contend with the fact that the
kind of external states that you are
dealing with
are composed of sentient creatures like
you
and that they also have beliefs keith
why don't we talk about the
main formalism for the free energy
principle
sure so the free energy principle comes
down to
the equation that we're showing here on
on the screen which is that the free
energy
is the summation of of two important
pieces
the energy which is a measure of
how well your model fits the
observations or the evidence
that you're observing and then the
second piece which
in a lot of ways is really the more
important piece
of the free energy is the entropic
contribution
and so that's the kl divergence if you
will between
your model of the world and then the
actual
uh hidden model of the world and the
divergence between those two it has two
important pieces to it and i want to
kind of call out i want to highlight
one here which let's circle right there
that's purely the the model entropy okay
so that's actually the the negative of
the model entropy and the in the kl
divergence
and so as the model gains greater and
greater entropy
and note that that's a positive quantity
there
okay then up in the free energy
it's being subtracted from the free
energy so the higher the entropy of your
model
the lower the free energy so as you're
trying to minimize free energy
you've got two competing criteria one is
to fit observations
better and better but that will require
more and more complex models
which will have lower and lower entropy
and therefore they will be
subtracting less from the free energy so
what you're trying to do is find the
model
that fits the data well while also
maintaining
a high entropy and the reason why that's
important
for survival is that if you have a
higher entropy model
it's maintaining greater flexibility to
adapt
to incoming information so if you recall
log evidence and any associated bands
like free energy or
an elbow edwin slow bound in machine
learning
can be written as a as the accuracy
minus the complexity and the complexity
is just the divergence between your
posterior and your prime
belief distributions so
that is a really and possibly the more
important part
of the free energy the accuracy is well
understood but
doing it in a minimally complex and
maximally compressed way that
that's the heart of it so recall the
complexity is just the relative entropy
between the prior
and the first year it is the degree to
which you change your mind
in the face of this new data or this new
sensory evidence the free energy
principle equally weights
accuracy and complexity might it be the
case that we need to have a temperature
parameter like a kind of
knob to tweak the relative contribution
between
accuracy and complexity would such a
parameter be useful
i'm wondering is in the free energy
principle term with the complexity i'm
wondering if maybe there should be a
multiplier there like an alpha
something like a boltzmann constant that
allows me to tweak
the relative balance between accuracy
and complexity
there are two answers to that question
first of all absolutely not
the whole the whole point of
dissolving that exploration exploitation
dilemma the whole point
of putting the information gain in the
same space and
in the same currency and on the same
footing as your
log prior preferences your reward your
utility
your belmonesque like imperatives is
that there is a seamless
exchange in terms of gnats natural units
between the decomposition of your
expected free energy
in terms of this intrinsic value and
this extrinsic utilitarian
pragmatic value the other answer is
absolutely yes
but in order to in order to
acknowledge that if you're just trying
to explain
the necessary properties dynamics
of systems that self-organize to some
non-equilibrium steady state
you are saying nothing about the nature
of that city state other than it is at
steady state so it could be very high
entropy steady state it could be very
low entropy
steady state it could be very hot it
could be very cold
you haven't really committed to any kind
of
steady state which means that
it's slightly disingenuous to say that
the imperative for everything is to
minimize
say a free energy functional and if you
parameterize up with a particular
parameter and we'll call it alpha
as a not to your question then suddenly
you really do need this alpha and this
alpha gets in
exactly as you say as a knob on
the expected complexity versus the
expected accuracy
or ambiguity that's not in the
literature
so there are ongoing debates amongst the
younger people who love the maths of
this about
whether we just need a generic kale
divergence
or whether we need to exclude bits to
get to expected free energy
you have to really think about the
relative importance for this steady
state of
technically the risk and the ambiguity
and the sensory entropy
so that's again that's a bit of an open
question which i'm hoping will be
resolving about a year's time
at which point your alpha will occur and
i'll try to call it alpha in your honor
one of the previous guests to our show
dr hari valpola
the ceo of curious ai and a
computational
applied neuroscientist he centers in a
couple of questions for fristen actually
and
the answer was quite interesting but the
crux of it
is the brain is highly specialized right
and
is the free energy principle an
oversimplification for what's going on
in the brain
if you take a young child around nine
months old
the critical period for learning the
phonemes of your mother tongue
and you play some speech from the radio
the result is
nothing but if you play the same speech
during a social interaction
the child will learn to discriminate the
phonemes in the speech
structure matters structures of the
brain
being very finely attuned to
and adapted to the context in which
they're that they're making their
inferences
what would normally cast that in terms
of
structure learning also known as
bayesian model selection
so this notion speaks to a simple
understanding
of evolution or as nature's way of doing
natural
bayesian model selection i.e natural
selection where you
operationally associate the adaptive
fitness with the probability this
phenotype
exists which is just the evidence that
it is there the probability of
finding that phenotyping place you know
but
it is on some reading provably true
that for any system or agent to regulate
its environment it has to embody or be a
good model
of that environment what does that mean
its structure must somehow
recapitulate the structure of the
environment generating
that it has to control or it has to
engage with
so it is hardly unsurprising that
the delicate deep hierarchically
structured
connectivity we find in their brain and
in a variation auto encoder
is a natural thing that has emerged from
the evolution of these architectures
that all
are conforming with the principle of
free energy minimization
what about daniel kahneman's system one
and system two
of cognition do those fit into the free
energy principle
he cites kahneman system one and system
two of thinking
there's this famous test where if you
give monkeys a sequence of cards with a
hidden pattern on
which need to be classified into two
classes humans
suddenly click they see the hidden rule
because their system two kicks in and
they start getting 100 accuracy very
quickly but you don't see that
with monkeys so valpolia was saying that
he doesn't see
how that phenomenon could be explained
by the free energy principle
recent thinking about the cerebellum is
that it plays the role
of actually a supervisor so it may well
be the case that the cerebellum plays a
role in the amortization
of carefully acquired skilled
movements that become increasingly
skilled
as the cerebellum watches the cortex
in that sense the cerebellum can i think
be
very usefully understood in terms of
being involved
in supervised learning but i'd actually
turn it on its head
and basically say it's been supervised
by the cortex but in a way that allows
the
cerebellum to tell the cortex well
normally you do it like that
do we do our belief updating and a bit
of planning as inference
or do we just do what we've always done
habitually respond quickly and
efficiently
by harnessing something that has already
been amortized
and that i think is a really interesting
interpretation of habitization
versus deliberative thinking which from
the point of view of a neuroscientist
would be the equivalent of
system one versus versus system two in
that sort of edge between machine
learning
and reinforcement learning sometimes
referred to as model-free versus
model-based
so it's the bread and butter of a
jobbing neuroscientist
certainly a systems neuroscientist to
understand
the computational architectures and the
nature of
message passing implied by
either belief updating or predictive
coding or variational message passing
how it is enacted physiologically on a
neuroanatomy
that has a deep structure connor asked
fristen about predictive coding
there has been a paper that says that
predictive coding
can approximate back propagation in
arbitrary graphs
i'm sure a friend of mine has
contributed that and if there's any
sense that prop has been demeaned as
something which is not
that's really central to everything then
i think that's probably wrong
so from my perspective it is
in very the case that the
gradients with respect to anything of
variation free energy
can be written down as an a prediction
error
which means that if you believe that the
universe of
interesting things is performing a
gradient flow
on a variational free energy functional
then you also believe that they are
by the chain rule minimizing their
prediction error
i think that's one of the first times
that premier scientists actually say
something positive about backdrop
and does the free energy principle tell
us anything about the origin of life
for example abiogenesis if we take for
granted that the free energy
principle explains a great deal about
how
certain systems of the kind we've been
elucidating
will function does it explain the origin
of those systems is it almost
unavoidable
that we will end up with these deeply
structured
delicate markov blanketed systems
that become increasingly rich and have
longer longer information lengths and
more itinerant dynamics
as the universe unfolds it would be
great to know the answer
to that and to have a tractable
mathematical formulation of that
i'm afraid that the free energy
principle in its vanilla form as it
currently stands
does not give you that no all it says is
if that thing has evolved
these are the properties that it must
possess but at least it can tell us
we should continue exploring and looking
around to address that uncertainty
yes cover yes of course some better
better free energy principle
next we're going to talk about richard
feynman's path integral this is
something that
fristen referred to many times during
the session today
yeah so path the path integral
formulation
let's say of which is essential for
quantum electrodynamics for one thing
is quite interesting and actually it
should be familiar
in in one sense to to let's say
bayesians or people who do a lot of
conditional probability theory because
they may recall that the probability of
say a particular event
is actually equal to the summation
of the probability of that of that event
given like let's say some other state of
the world
okay over all possible states of that a
in other words this is marginalization
or the marginal probability
if you have a bunch of possible worlds
what you have to do is sum over all
possible worlds and when that's applied
to physics
say in the case of quantum
electrodynamics what it's saying is that
if you have many possible ways in which
let's pretend the photon could come from
a
and end up over b it could travel along
any one of these many paths here
that if you're considering the total
probability of that actually happening
you have to sum
over all these possible states waiting
by their amplitude
and that's a very beautiful consequence
because in some real essence we don't
think that the photon
say travels every one of those possible
paths
but it's as if it did and why this is
important in the free energy principle
is that when we live in a universe where
you have to perform
this summation over all possible worlds
that means that inherently we need a
system that can model
probabilities and can transform those
probabilities
accurately according to the laws of
probability theory
and another interesting consequence of
it is that if we're playing this
repeated game where we're trying to
survive over time
and we're getting in new information all
the time about these many possible
future paths
we have to model the world in a flexible
way we have to keep an
entropic model a model that has a high
entropy that's able to adjust
as new information comes in about those
probable paths
how did he find it talking to uh
professor fristen oh i i really i have
to say i
very much enjoyed talking to professor
fristen
when i went into the preparation for
this call some weeks back
i would say i was probably more
skeptical of the free energy principle
than i am now but as we've learned a lot
over the last few weeks and then really
having a chance to
pose some questions uh to professor
fristen
and hear his answers uh yeah i think
this is a very interesting principle
uh and i think it's i think we'll find
increasingly as we become more
sophisticated with both
the modeling of the principle and the
application of the principle
that we are going to find many systems
that that conform to it
so i find it quite interesting and
completely enjoyed talking to him i wish
i lived next door to him i'd probably
hop over there once in a while to have a
sherry and just discuss
deep topics he has such an intuitive
understanding of deep topics that
it's sometimes hard to keep pace but if
you can it's
it's very fun yeah because if you look
at the free energy principle on
wikipedia
it even says at the top of the article
that
it's very complicated even experts in
the field
just have trouble getting their heads
wrapped around it and when you listen to
professor fristen
talk he clearly is a polymath he has
deep knowledge of so many different
fields and it's really interesting to
have
all of that embodied in one person
because the level of cross-pollination
is really quite impressive but by the
same token
there's so much jargon and he's diving
into so many different areas
that it does make it quite difficult to
follow what he's talking about
i think that wikipedia has got it wrong
that it's complicated
i think that we often make the mistake
of thinking that things that are hard to
understand are inherently complicated
and i think that's wrong i think
simple and easy are very very different
concepts it's possible for
simple concepts to be very difficult to
understand and indeed to take
human civilization thousands of years to
discover
and i think this i think the free energy
principle falls under the category of
simple but very difficult to understand
very deep
deep concepts almost like some of the
concepts that rest
at the foundation of mathematical logic
or
probability theory you know when you
start to think about puzzles like
this sentence is false right or if you
think about what is the meaning of
probability is
is it a frequency is it a degree of
rational belief
why or why not you know these are very
deep concepts
at the end they can be expressed
relatively simply
on paper but still be very difficult to
understand
thank you very much they're very
informed questions i got a sense you
knew the answers before you asked them
that's how i felt
anyway we really hope you've enjoyed the
episode today we've had so much fun
making it
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments and we'll
see you back
next week the like new yorkers are rude
and blunt
you know they're they're they're very
direct and they'll be about it
well germans are polite but blunt like
germans will very politely tell you your
code is completely unacceptable
but they'll be very polite about it
that's kind of slightly similar to uh
southern culture or classic southern
culture in the us
it's very polite but straightforward
like they don't like beating around the
bush you know but i would say they don't
go as far
to the rude spectrum while being blunt
like they still are
straight forward but politely i've i'm
super sensitive to people beating around
the bush
yes that's it that's why i was funny
that when you told me you were like a
traitor in new york i was like
yeah this makes a lot of sense like
straightforward and polite
i love germans i worked with a few of
them in my lab and
in graduate school and i like i also
like how
rule-based they are like there are rules
and you follow the rules when you open
the door you close the door you close it
you don't leave it half open
it's like i love it that's true it's
true it's both
a blessing and a curse i used to work
with some radioactive dyes and i
disposed of one in the wrong container
so i disposed of like
the betas in the alpha container or
something and it caused like a
cost like a couple hundred dollars or
something the german postdoc there was
so
like pissed at me but polite he's like
just keeps going on and on about how can
you put
a in the b container right that's just
not
how it happens that should have never
happened i don't know what we should do
about this
but something needs to happen to make
sure you never do that again
yeah that is such a german thing i i've
heard that exact conversation with
people before
he would keep just wouldn't let this go
i'm like yeah i'm sorry i screwed up you
know it wasn't a good enough explanation
it was like
what is broken that we need to fix so
this never happens again
that's the most german thing i've ever
heard hello hello
hi there hello hello professor fristen
great to meet you
nice to see you fantastic now i'm not an
expert on etiquette is it dr fristin or
professor fristen which is more correct
in england it would be professor pristin
okay in the states i think
i've heard that teachers are called
professors so they prefer to be called
doctors
right in the uk it's a professor gotcha
and tech industry is first names only
[Laughter]
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel
and podcast with my two compadres connor
leahy
and mit phd dr keith duggar
now today we have a very special guest
professor fristen
he is a british neuroscientist at
university college london
and an authority on brain imaging he
studied natural sciences
physics and psychology at the university
of cambridge in 1980
and completed his medical studies at
king's college hospital
in london a strong indicator of
professor fristen's illustrious career
is that he's been cited over 206
thousand
times with an aged index of 239
in 2016 he was ranked the most
influential neuroscientist on semantic
scholar
and carl fristan pioneered and developed
the single most powerful technique
for analyzing the results of brain
imaging studies
he's currently a welcome trust principal
fellow and scientific director
of the welkin trust center for
neuroimaging his main contribution to
theoretical neurobiology
is the variational free energy principle
also known as active inference
in the bayesian brain the free energy
principle is a formal statement
that the existential imperative for any
system
which survives in the changing world can
be cast as an inference problem
the probability of existing as the
evidence that you exist
if you will you can always interpret
anything which exists as being separate
to the environment it exists in
carl asserts that existence is a kind of
interface
between the interior and the exterior so
the free energy principle which is
closely related to the bayesian brain
hypothesis
is a simple postulate with complicated
implications
any adaptive change in the brain or
indeed any system which exists
will minimize surprise or free energy as
cold puts it
this minimization could be on any time
scale
or on any system which resists a
tendency
to disorder from single cell organisms
to social networks the bayesian brain
hypothesis states
that the brain is confronted with
ambiguous sensory evidence
which it interprets by making inferences
about the hidden states which
caused the sensory data so
is the brain an inference engine the key
concept separating fristen's idea from
traditional stochastic reinforcement
learning methods and even bayesian
reinforcement learning methods
is moving away from goal directed
optimization
belief based updating combines the
ambiguous information with prior beliefs
about the nature of the world the
missing information problem is something
which dogs many areas of machine
learning
as we discussed on our gpt3 episode last
week
implementing the bayes rule directly is
often computationally intractable
and computer scientists drew inspiration
from the physics world
for creating approximate inference
techniques called variational bayesian
methods
and carl's active inference method uses
these techniques to great effect
anyway professor fristen it's an
absolute honor to have you on the show
welcome
and how did you come up with this
exciting principle
well first of all let me congratulate
you on that beautiful introduction
you said everything that i could
possibly say in the next hour and a half
so i'll just try and recapitulate what
you said the road
to the free energy principle as you have
just described it
started really when i was a student
aspiring
to put together maths and psychology so
in those days it would have been known
as mathematical psychology nowadays
computational neuroscience
and leading of computational
neuroscience into machine learning
so from the start that was the ambition
more practically though
as your brief resume indicated i got a
bit distracted by becoming
a doctor and then a psychiatrist in you
know
out of clinical compassion but also
partly out of an interest in
understanding how the brain works
and then inevitably one gets back to
mathematical formalisms the
the the principles that underlie the
sentient behavior with which we are
gifted
and the product of that was the the free
energy principle or active inference in
a sort of more cognitive neuroscience
setting i'd like to ask you about two
kind of related topics
that have interested in machine learning
lately is i was interested if you were
familiar with the work of jeff hawkins
from numenta who
is a unsung hero among machine learning
inspirations
and he had a quote saying it is the
ability to make predictions about the
future that is the crux of intelligence
and recently with uh machine learning
progress such as with gpt3
which you know is a better and better
predictive model and some would argue
including myself also becomes more and
more intelligent in a meaningful way so
my question is prediction
really all it takes for intelligence or
is there more to it i think prediction
figures very centrally in the sort of
dynamics that we're talking about can
answer that question from
two perspectives often cast in terms of
the high road and the low road
to that formal understanding of things
like active imprints
so that the low road would really be a
bottom-up approach thinking what does
the brain do
and on that view or on that approach
the the big move in the 21st century has
been
towards predictive processing and it
started with predictive coding as a nice
metaphor for
message passing in the brain now
generalized to subsume
action and decision-making and choices
and epistemic foraging
and so andy clark coined the the phrase
predictive processing to it to
accommodate that
and in that sort of formulation of
sentient behavior
prediction is absolutely essential at
two levels and
from the point of view of predictive
coding obviously it's baked into the
title
that you're you're trying to predict
what
you will see under some belief about the
sort of latent states generating some
data or you could formulate that in
terms of compression
minimizing message length and efficient
making sense of data or unpacking data
the prediction in that sense is i think
not quite the kind of prediction that
you're asking about which is
uh which has this sort of temporal
aspect sort of the forecasting or
anticipatory
aspect of prediction however once you
move
predictive coding into a
sort of bayesian filtering setting and
you put dynamics in play
then when you're trying to predict the
trajectories in the moment you are
implicitly
predicting a short-term future so i
think sort of
prediction in the dynamical the temporal
sense starts to bite again
beyond that there is in the
neurosciences
an appreciation that that's not the end
of the game you can get a long way
on this low road of understanding in
terms of understanding
how we act and perceive and how action
is in the service of perception
vice versa through treating motor
behavior responses
of an embodied brain in terms of
reflexes and this would be very much a
predictive coding
explanation of the action perception
cycle essentially equipping
predictive coding with reflexes of this
sort of in the moment sort yeah you
could write down in terms of
differential equations or
kalman bc filter but the more
interesting game
is i think better cast in terms of
planning as
inference so actually including
what i'm doing as a random variable in
your
inference problem and enabling you to
roll out much further into the future
and ask
well what would happen if i did that
what would my beliefs
be about the state of the world in the
long term future and that gives a very
different
aspect to prediction that you're
predicting the consequences of any move
on the world
of any data that you might want to
sample how will that reduce my
uncertainty
what information will i gain what
relevance does that have
for the kinds of preferred outcomes that
characterize me
as a goal-directed creature so
i think prediction in its full and
glorious anticipatory
sense really takes center stage and when
people talk about active imprints that
sort of implicitly
they're talking about this sort of
fuller deep
temporal approach to inferring
what should i do next and then from
those inferences selecting the next
move to to make so in that sense the
other sort of the hierarchical temporal
models that
dalip and jeff hawkins have have been
talking about for
you know decades as well and i can
remember reviewing as a handling editor
the first publication plus computational
biology on the on this work and it was
refreshing and i think that that's
exactly
uh the kind of hangers inference in the
future
consequent on or conditioned upon the
different kinds of policies
or sequential uh sequences of actions
that i could
entertain bringing time for center stage
in into the inference problem
the high role i should just add so using
a completely different language now
that i would use as a physicist to
promote the importance of prediction
it takes a slightly different view it
says well to understand
the first principles that underlie
sentient behavior
you have to understand the dynamics of
self-organization in particular
self-organization of systems that are
open
to the environment to their eco niche to
their
heat bath their heat reservoir and when
one does that you can use uh
dynamics and random dynamical systems to
say
the kind of moves and and changes
of the systemic states must
have this form of predictive coding
or bayesian or kalman like filtering in
the moment
and that's relatively straightforward to
show and there was a hint
of the requisite mathematical apparatus
you needed to make those assertions in
the introduction
and specifically mark off blankets that
separate me from not me
so that would be grade one if you like
uh prediction it's just that we have
dynamics and
the dynamics required a
self-organization to non-equilibrium
steady
state require some in the moment kind of
prediction
so where is the sort of the the higher
end
anticipatory of dynamics well that that
comes in
through fyman's path integral
formulation and
thinking not just about the flow of the
dynamics
of self-organization at this point in
time
but trajectories into the future and the
probability distributions over those
trajectories and particularly
the states that act upon the outside
the if you like formally characterize
what we do
over extended periods of time so when
you bring the path integral
uh formalism to bear on these
non-equilibrium steady state
distributions then
you can sort of say what kinds of
policies as i move into the future
are more likely and which are less
likely and then things get much more
interesting
and we talk about sort of ambiguity and
risk and what the imperatives are
for long-term behaviors and underneath
all that there is an interpretation
that i'm really trying to predict or you
can interpret this
in terms of inferring the most likely
paths
basically as resting upon a prediction
of
states of the world in the future
conditioned upon a particular sequence
of actions
or policy one of the things that i think
is very interesting about the
free energy formulation is that
prediction is
half the story so getting accurate
predictions about the future
while very important is juxtaposed
with keeping your options open keeping a
flexible mind
keeping a high entropy model of the
world so that as you encounter perhaps
new situations
it has the flexibility to adapt more
quickly
that incoming information and that
because it's a repeated game
you're not just trying to optimize the
very next step only but
the entire trajectory of your existence
if you will
and and that's captured in the free
energy principle inside the kl
divergence part of that is the entropy
of
my model of the world and the larger
that is
the lower the free energy is this
interesting
interplay and you also point out in a
video too that
when it's this repeated game it's
related in a way to what in other fields
is called the
exploration versus exploitation kind of
trade-off like in the multi-armed bandit
world where
i can take an action that's maximally
exploited but but i may not learn very
much
and then on the other hand i can take an
action that's purely just to learn about
the world but may not
achieve much of my other objective and
what i love about that is it explains
why we're always so tempted to push the
button
why people always want to press the
button and see what happens or go out
and explore
even if there's no immediate benefit and
it has so many connections to
things like novelty search and multi-arm
banded analysis
it's quite interesting yeah you bring so
many fascinating points there yeah
and under robotics intrinsic motivation
and robotic artificial curiosity and
the schmidt hoover-like sensor which
itself
all comes back down to this minimizing
the complexity
and paradoxically and celebrating
uncertainty
so if you allow me you've made so many
good points there i i can't resist just
highlighting the first of all
predictions only half the story
absolutely i mean why are we predicting
we're predicting
in order to infer what to do next so the
doing the action
the inactive aspect really becomes
essential thing in terms of
well things that are written into the
description like self-organization how i
organize myself how
what i do and if you're in data science
that would be basically
how do i optimally update a mine can i
find asian optimum design principles
written into the formalism the
variational formalism that
the free energy principle so i think
just saying that
perception is great if you're just
studying the visual cortex
or you're interpreting some given
pixelated image but the real challenge
is really
how do you go and take that picture and
how do you move your eyes around
and sample that information that's going
to make much more sense in the world
so it's all in the service of what i'm
going to do you mentioned that the kl
divergence
the central role of relative entropies
in this sort of variational construct
i think that your for me that is so
important
so a very simple perspective on free
energy which i think is useful
certainly for students is it just to
remind them that the free energy is some
expected potential some expected
utility if you like and complemented by
the entropy
and in minimizing the free energy you're
also trying to maximize the entropy
we've seen sometimes
counter-intuitive but it is exactly that
which is really mandated by things like
occam's principle
and very practically relevant so if you
don't do that
if you don't put that uncertainty into
the game so you don't commit
to a very precise explanation for these
data
then you're going to run into things
like sharp minima
and you're going to be searching for
resolutions of that in terms of
broadening your uncertainty flattening
that free energy landscape just
to try and secure those those those flat
minima
where you can be more reasonably assure
that you've got some global minima
say in standard deep learning or a
machine learning context
you know that would be a story you could
tell just about the composition of
why free energy rests upon entropies and
relative entropies
but you took us um straight to the heart
of
the sort of deeper in time
inference that comes along with the
active inference which is this sort of
this implicit imperative to reduce
uncertainty
that can often be described in terms of
responding to salience
or epistemic affordance to say if i did
that what would happen what would i know
what information
would i gain novelty you mentioned so
technically what we tend to do is to
talk about the resolution of uncertainty
or the information
gain that is formally described by kl
divergence between
my beliefs about states of the world
with and without those sensory samples
or observations that i would get if i
did that
so that kl divergence can be applied to
unknown states the world and that would
be driving behaviors like
looking over there to make sure that my
hypothesis that was a butterfly or a
bird
or a candle was the best explanation for
these sort of peripheral visual
sensations
but you've also got unknowns for example
in a deep learning
scenario the the connection strengths
you know in the brain
parameters that underwrite our brain
connectivity that
encode the lawful contingencies and
statistical regulations
of likelihood mappings or probability
transition matrices
so these don't change quickly in time
but this still
are equipped with a posterior belief or
some
some stochastic representation about
which you can reduce uncertainty
and we call that novelty so if you can
get yourself into a situation
where you reduce your uncertainty about
the contingencies and the parameters of
your generative model
then you're responding to their again an
epistemic affordance
there is exactly this a resolution of
uncertainty formally we would write that
down as an expected
free energy i don't know if this helps
but one way
i find useful to think about this and
indeed explain to
to students is free energy is a bound on
log evidence simply the probability
of some data under a model of
how i thought those data were generated
and you can always split that into
accuracy and complexity so if i have a
statistician
and i wanted to minimize my physics
free energy or maximize my machine
learning free energy
which is because it's just an evidence
lower bound and so you'd find in a
variational auto encoder what am i doing
if i decompose the log evidence into
accuracy and complexity what i'm trying
to do
is minimize the complexity
of my accurate expectations and then we
get back to
minimum description lengths the
underlying say
you know monograph like complexity
formulations of your
most efficient coding and the like so
you've got this
way of looking at self-evidencing in the
sense
of just forming good beliefs
of how my data were generated
in terms of providing the simplest
but at most accurate explanations or
accounts of the data at hand
so if we come back to this to the
previous
discussion about what would happen in
the deep future so i did a deep research
over all the sequences of moves that i
could make
what would the expected accuracy and the
expected
complexity look like and if you write
that down
they come out as things like risk and
ambiguity
so the expected accuracy or more
precisely expected inaccuracy the
negative accuracy the negative
probability of your data under beliefs
about their causes
becomes ambiguity becomes the
conditional uncertainty if you like
about
the observations if you knew them and
the the expected complexity becomes risk
or it has exactly the same form that
you'd find in kl control theory
or risk sensitive control in economics
it's just the
relative entropy or the divergence
between what you think will happen if
you did that
and what a priori you think is going to
happen which
normally people treat as a sort of the
preferred
outcome the kind of things that a
creature or a system or an agent like me
would normally encounter so that
ambiguity
is actually the thing that you were
talking about the reason why we push
that button
or open that door or go on that trip
or go into that google page you know it
is
written into it is if you like the
homolog
of our aspirations for accurate accounts
of all the sensory and other data that
we have to assimilate
when we consider the expectation in the
future conditioned on what would
actually do
we're getting quite close to the center
of the bullseye here and we're talking
about the dichotomy between belief-free
and belief-based methods so you've been
sketching out this really interesting
idea that we can take subsequent actions
by maximizing the expectation over a a
generative model of
states in distribution and subsequent
policies
but the alternative is so-called
goal-directed behavior now you've said
in your papers that
goal-directed behaviors is fine for
learning kind of basic habitual policies
but
you cite this wonderful example with an
owl you say that an
owl doesn't necessarily know where the
mouse is in in the field there might be
some ambiguity there might be some
uncertainty
and using a simple goal directed policy
the hour would just go straight to the
mouse and
and try and eat the mouse now it's quite
interesting to contrast
your approach to other forms of let's
say bayesian reinforcement learning or
traditional stochastic reinforcement
learning
of course normally there's this value
function that needs to be either
computed directly in the non-stochastic
setting using the bellman equations or
or some other method but but your
approach is a stark
departure away from having this value
function
again you've said everything that i
could possibly say so
i'll send you on my next lecture tour
that'll take the pressure off me yeah
absolutely and of course i
forgot to just to highlight this sort of
exploitation exploration
dilemma that has dog 20th century
thinking
of course that just dissolves in the
21st century because
you know risk and ambiguity sometimes
you can
exchange the the terms in this expected
free energy formulation
uh and re-express that as an intrinsic
um
and extrinsic value where the intrinsic
value is something that people in
robotics artificial curiosity would
recognize
as that's of epistemic information gain
uh part
and the extrinsic value is just the
expected utility of the expected reward
and in minimizing this mixture that just
is the expected free energy you you've
got exploration and exploitation
sold for free in the right order so you
normally
see this food in the fridge before you
start preparing your your meal you don't
do it the other way around
so that's you know what you were hinting
at in terms of the owl
opening its fridge and searching it's
slightly disingenuous of me
i think to use such a stark
contrast dialectic between what is in
essence a whole bunch of things
predicated on the bellman optimality
principle and
contrasts that with another way of doing
it which is the
which is essentially a variational
hamilton's principle station reaction so
the free energy principle inherits from
the physics
of non-equilibrium that you will find
from thyman's path integral formulation
of quantum electrodynamics right through
to hamilton's equations of
your motion so there are these this is
the variational principle that is the
first principle that we were mentioning
before
so the question is do you choose between
variational principles of station
reaction or do you go for
optimality principles and in that choice
what's the big commitment you're making
and
you said it you said that the bellman
optimality principle is only fit for
purpose
if there exists a value function of
states that will ensue
if i commit to that action whereas
the variational principles of least
action being a path integral
of an energy and an energy being a log
probability of a probability
distribution immediately tells you
that the objective function if you want
to cast it in terms of
normative theories of optimization the
objective function
is a function of a probability
distribution so
it has to be belief based a problem if
you
if read a probability distribution is a
bayesian belief
so if you allow me to talk about beliefs
simply as
uh conditional probability distributions
in the sense of
belief propagation or bayesian beliefs
then we know that the the from
physics the objective function the
lipoon off function
the cost function has to be a
functional function of bayesian beliefs
so that comes back to your point that if
you go down the bellman route
the rl route the optimal control route
then you are predicting everything on a
value
function of states if on the other hand
you go down a variational or a physics
route
then your objective function has to be a
functional of beliefs about states and
that's where you get
the resolution of uncertainty that's
where searching gets into the mix
because
to search is to resolve uncertainty but
uncertainty
and surprise and all of these other
attributes
of belief updating are all attributes of
probabilistic beliefs probability
distributions so you know you have to
have a
function of probability distributions in
order to account
for sentient behavior and i would say
including goal directed behavior why is
that disingenuous well
it's disingenuous because of course what
you can do
is take this more general formalism this
variational formalism
and take out of it all the uncertainty
and then you can get back to the bellman
optionality principle so really
there's not a dialectic here it's just
that the
optimality principle deals with a
special but very ubiquitous and
pragmatically very important case where
you can discount
various sources uncertainty so common
examples here
let's ignore the partially observed
aspect of a problem let's assume that
our observations tell us everything we
need to know about
latent states causing data or latent
states of the plant that i'm trying to
try to control
so that takes ambiguity out of the
expected free energy
before before you do anything what
you're left with where you're left with
the expected risk
what's that's the unexpected complexity
so that's just a probabilistic measure
relative entropy measure
of the distance probabilistically
between your prior preferences your
goals your your rewarding states
and what you think will happen so if you
say look
now let's assume for simplicity
that it doesn't matter every which way
that i can do this
the uncertainty about what's going to
happen is not going to change
that means that risk now doesn't play
any role anymore other than
to um score the expected
um utility or the expected log of your
prior preferences
that just is bay's bayesian decision
theory
so you can get quite easily back to what
was
a deliberate but maliciously engineered
dichotomy
you can sort of dismiss that just by
acknowledging that
you only need to worry about uncertainty
and epistemics
when you put uncertainty and not knowing
your into the mix i'd like to i'd like
to explore that as you put it
maliciously engineered
false dichotomy a little bit further but
in a different context
and it's one of the marcotte blanket for
example you were with uh sean carroll
not long ago and i think he asked does a
hurricane have a markov blanket
and and he said well no it doesn't and
that's that's quite annoying actually
that it doesn't have a conv or maybe the
eternal flame is sort of the the nemesis
because
it doesn't we get to this when is a pile
of sand
a pile of sand what i'm curious about is
does the concept of a markov blanket
for the purposes of uh contemplating the
free energy
principle can it be a fuzzy marcotte
blanket so
you know just for an inanimate example i
can imagine a markov blanket around the
moon and one around the earth
but on the other hand they
gravitationally interact but i don't
think that
precludes me from thinking about
dimensions of the free energy principle
even if even if there are interactions
that maybe i
that pierce the boundary if you will but
still
if it's enough of a boundary enough of a
blanket
if you will i can still think about in
useful ways is that true i mean do we
really need
an exact markov blanket or is it
flexible enough that it can be quite a
fuzzy boundary
there's an excellent question and the
honest answer is i i don't really know
at this stage
what what is known uh and in not knowing
i mean that in positive way that
this is a future challenge i think
people will contend with
in the next few years and i'll and i'll
try to explain why that's important from
my perspective
the the crisp and clear consequences of
having a markov blanket is when one
unpacks it right through to the path
integral
formulation the implications for the
good trajectories in terms of minimizing
expected free energy really do rest upon
that being a well-defined markov blanket
which as you say is the mechanism that
allows for these
connections and influences at a distance
that would
keep the moon in orbit around the earth
for example
whilst at the same time accommodating
the conditional independences
that enable me to distinguish the moon
from something else
so in an idealized formulation the
markov blanket exists at non-equilibrium
steady state so it exists in eternity
in a very crisp and well-defined way
that there are specific
conditional independences that allow for
a vicarious coupling between the inside
and the outside
so it's the device that gets you out of
20th century equilibrium physics so
we're not talking about
closed systems anymore we're talking
about uh non-equilibrium steady states
so
we're really in the sort of the things
that people like sean carroll a lot of
other people
are contending with at the moment and
the physics of open systems and
self-organizing systems
and a markup plan plays a incredible
incredibly crucial role here
in demarcating the edge of the system as
it were
and it allows you to identify something
so anything
has to have a markov blanket strictly
speaking for a particular
period of time just as an aside
what happens when you do that is stuff
on the inside the markov blanket
has to have a kind of synchrony with
stuff on the outside
and in virtue of those conditional
dependencies that stipulatively define
the markov
blanket you can now treat the internal
states as parameterizing
probability distributions or belief
distributions about
external states so there's quite a
fundamental
bit of information geometry that you've
been to the table
when you have a markov blanket that
suddenly you can interpret
the machinations on the inside in your
computer
or your variation auto encoder or your
brain
as having beliefs of a bayesian sort
about what caused these data what's
going on the outside
so that's absolutely crucial for the
whole sort of active inference
and certainly representational or
realist or anti-realist sort of
philosophical interpretations so the
markup blanket is absolutely central
everything inherits from the markov
blanket so everything else was in play
before
we have the vodka plank equation we have
the scrolling wave equation we have
variational principles of stationary
action and pathetical formulations
that's all there
all you need to do is to drop the markov
blanket in and then you get
active inference so to move on to your
more challenging question
does a hurricane or the eternal flame
have a mark of black blanket well
strictly speaking no it doesn't
because you've got this fuzzy leaking it
is
from the point of view somebody's wanted
to simplify things as a physicist
very irritating but of course it's all
also incredibly important and
challenging
so where would you go to try and
understand
these fluctuating blankets where you
have exchanges so
just technically you've got external
states and then you've got blanket
states that intervene
between the internal states and the
external states
and yet with something like a candle
flame or a hurricane
you seem to have this exchange that what
was once an external state becomes in a
blanket state and what was once
a blanket state becomes an external
state and i worry about this every time
i cut my fingernails
or have my hair cut at what point did my
mark or blanket become
an external state so there's clearly
there's clearly a bit of
work to be done mathematically to
accommodate
markov blankets as themselves
dynamically random objects
my guess is that you're going to
probably go back to the work of
irkov who was one of the key
intellectual architects
of ergot history and ergodic theory and
he
was at one point occupied by the notion
of wandering sets so if we think of the
markov blanket as a partition
of all the states of the universe into
lots and lots of particles that comprise
the internal states and their mark of
blankets
and if you consider that partition into
particles
as a partitioning into subsets and then
you bring
wandering sets into play you can now
start to see a mechanics and a
mathematics
where you do actually can now actually
explain things like hurricanes
and candles and just for interest
literally a couple of weeks ago there
was a nice
paper in frontiers treating the
biosphere as a markov blanket
so you know that there is practical and
important sort of you know pressures
in order to formalize what are the
markov blankets of these large-scale
structures
and my guess is that the notion of
wandering sets and the
time scales over which internal states
exchange with external states and
internal states external states exchange
with blanket states are going to be
going to be an important issue and i say
that because of course
we develop what point when i i'm born
and what point am i die
does my can i what happens to my mark
off blanket
reproduction 3d printers printing
themselves
is a species of 3d printers one big
markov blanket or
do do actually drill down and just say
markup only really exists
for the lifetime of the 3d printer so
all of these issues i think speak to
exactly what you're drilling down on
which is how can you
accommodate fluctuations and
if you like physics of non-equilibria
not of states of a universe but of the
blanket or the partitions that define
the other markov blankets if we can
imagine
into the future maybe and if in the
spirit of the free energy principle
we maintain uncertainty about the free
energy principle
it may be the case that is we extend it
to say
wandering sets with wandering points we
may develop a mathematics of more of a
distance metric
this cloud of points is currently this
distance from a particular
wandering point and they're orbiting
around and there may be some
dynamics in there and then if we follow
a similar analysis we might end up
back at the free energy principle plus
another term
for example like there may be an extra
term over there which could be important
would that be kind of a
fair speculation of what might happen
well yeah that's very clever yes
yeah so i often say
in moments of vanity and pride that the
free energy
principle is one of the very few
principles that conforms to itself
it's trying to provide an accurate but
minimally complex explanation for
everything
and the only other thing that i know
that conforms to itself
is the principle of natural selection in
the sense that the theories of natural
selection themselves evolved
for perry and third world and in that
sense this notion that the free energy
principle
should accommodate a judicious amount of
uncertainty about itself is absolutely
right yeah
that's a very very clever observation in
terms of the form
i think that's probably right as well i
mean you're asking me to think about you
know where we might be in
in say 10 years time and so this is just
hand waving but certainly one could
imagine
variational principles of stationary
action applied
not to probability distributions over
states but
probability distributions over over
partitions uh
and sets and getting into some things
like category theory and the like
so one can see a sketch or an image
of the future kind of maths that there
might be
that might conserve the
relatively simple principles that
underwrite the free energy principle
but now applied at some one level up as
it were
so not to the actual system itself but
to the probabilistic configurations and
the partitions
that define that principle if i can zoom
out a little bit here
so the free energy principle is a lot
about
the idea of we want to gain information
to create a better more accurate model
of the world around us
and but there are situations in game
theory and decision theory where that's
actually not
fitness enhancing so a few examples here
you might not
want to learn the face of your kidnapper
because he's more likely to kill you
and there's the other thing where you
might so this is an information you
don't want to gain
and sometimes it's also useful to have
false beliefs for example it can be
useful to think you're smarter than you
actually are or more confident than you
actually are
because that will help you in social
situations yeah that's a fascinating
area and i see those
those sort of themes in many different
contexts wishful thinking
deliberately avoiding certain sources of
information
not wanting to open a letter that tells
you whether you've passed your exams or
a letter from the doctor that contains
your the results of your
recent scan for cancer for example there
are things that we don't want to know so
we're talking about
very metacognitive things in a sense
that i never heard that before about not
wanting to know the face of your
kidnapper but that's a
a beautiful example it really does tell
you that objective functions have to be
about beliefs and the consequences of
belief states
not states of the world so if there's
one example that tells you you're not
going to serve up with the bellman
optimality principle
that's going to be it but it also tells
you
that many of these real world problems
have to contend with the fact that the
kind of external states that you
are dealing with are composed of
sentient creatures like you
and that they also have beliefs so now
you get into the game
of putting lots of active inference
agents together
and multi-agent scenarios and
how you infer the degree of
sophistication with which you infer
the intentions of others and the belief
states of others and all
all that gets into these very deep and
enriched
generative models that themselves now
represent the belief states of other
active inference uh your optimization
machines
as it were one other level i think that
you can
understand these sometimes paradoxical
or counterintuitive expressions of
optimality
is just to acknowledge that
the whole of the bayesian brain
hypothesis
the whole basis of indeed free energy
principle
is a statement about prior beliefs
and as such prior beliefs
are going to be in the context of
self-evidencing necessarily optimistic
so if you remember before i was reading
prior beliefs about the outcomes
consequent on the behavior
as preferences and the only reason i say
preferences
is because if those are the kind of
states that i
typically find myself in so if i'm a
physicist though the attracting set of
my non-equilibrium steady state
then it looks as if i will always be
working towards these
prior states so they look literally
mathematically
attracting in the sense of being an
attracting set but also psychologically
attractive
and valuable and therefore the preferred
states that i
worked towards so baked into
a bayesian reading of the information
theoretic imperatives for choice
is an optimism you're always moving
towards or trying to solicit evidence
that confirms that you are an eternal
immortal well-loved warm creature
so it has to be like it can't be any
other way manifestations of that i
always find
appealing because they're just
statements of the fact it couldn't be
any other way
i have to believe myself to be an expert
in this or very proficient in that
in order to realize those
preferred fantasies through action to
actually
secure the evidence yes i am that kind
of thing without those priors without
those optimistic priors
you would not get the kind of active
inference that
underwrites our existence to come back
you know to some of the phrases that
tim was using to introduce their free
energy
we had this very interesting point from
conor about there may be
game theoretic pressures let's say to
drive down accuracy in in some sense
there could also be and i'm not sure if
this strays outside the free energy
principle or not
but implementation factors so
the lesson is back to maxwell's demons
and and all the very sophisticated kind
of
information engine analysis that people
have done
from then until now has shown that the
actual
recording and computation of information
is an entropic process it generates
entropy
and so even though the free energy
principle does have a term in there
which is the entropy of my
model per se i'm not sure if that
captures
the entropy associated and i mean the
thermodynamic entropy if you will
associated with actually maintaining and
operating that model
so it may be the case for example that
you reach a point where
increasing my intelligence a little bit
more cost me much more to
operate and maintain than it actually
buys me an improved accuracy for example
where do you see that trade-off does or
doesn't fit into the free energy
principle
i think the trade-off fits very neatly
in fact you could say that was
you know in large part constituent of
the free energy
principle in the following sense and
again you preempted everything that i
might have said about this but i'll say
it again so
the complexity that we were talking
about so if you recall
log evidence and any associated bands
like free energy or
an elbow edmond slower bound in machine
learning
can be written as a as the accuracy
minus the complexity and the complexity
is just the divergence between your
posterior and your prime belief
distributions
now that is a complexity cost it's also
exactly
the the cost that underwrites uh salon
off and
universal computation computational
formulations of generalized or universal
intelligence
it is the thing that drives compression
in predictive coding or engineering
applications of it
it is the thing that jurgen smith uber
would emphasize if he were
part of our conversation that sort of
complexity minimization so
that is a really and possibly the more
important part
of the free energy the accuracy is well
understood but
doing it in a minimally complex and a
minimally maximally compressed way
that that's the heart of it that's
important because by landauer's
principle
and the janinsky equality that also
directly one to one
dictates the number of jewels that
you'll expend
in belief updating when you move from
your prior to the posterior
so recall the complexity is just the
relative entropy between the prior
and the posterior it is the degree to
which you change your mind
in the face of this new data or this new
sensory evidence
and therefore is exactly
the changing of the erasure of bits of
information
that can be measured in gnats in natural
units of using natural logarithms
that via landauer's principle has an
exact
thermodynamic cost in joules so when
we're talking about
informationally efficient complexity
minimizing schemes
compression schemes from my perspective
anything that minimizes variational free
energy or
belief updating the minimizes
variational free energy
you are also exactly talking about the
most efficient way of doing it
thermodynamically
so what that means is if you want to
build
the best kind of computer one simple way
of scoring how good your computer is
is to take two machines that have the
same accuracy
and the one that uses less electricity
is the best one
and that will also by definition provide
the least complex
um account and thereby minimize its uh
minimize its free energy
so i think it's a really important
practical observation that what we're
aspiring to here
are really cheap and cheerful machines
that can
that can do do their sort of their
synthesis
just to make it a bit more concrete what
i'm wondering is in the free energy
principle term with the complexity
because i
completely agree and get the point
that's the crux that's the most
important term
i'm wondering if maybe there should be a
multiplier there like an alpha
something like a boltzmann constant that
allows me to tweak
the relative balance between accuracy
and complexity
yeah oh a temperature parameter yeah
that's a great question
there are two answers to that question
first of all absolutely not
the whole the whole point of
dissolving that exploration exploitation
dilemma the whole point
of putting the information gain in the
same space and in the same currency and
on the same footing
as your log prior preferences your
rewards your utility
your bellman-esque like imperatives is
that there is a
seamless exchange in terms of
gnats natural units between the
decomposition of your expected free
energy
in terms of this intrinsic value and
this extrinsic utilitarian pragmatic
value
one of the benefits of removing the
alpha
or beta or temperature coefficient on
the the complexity versus the the
accuracy
that for the expected free energy now
becomes risk and
ambiguity is that now you can talk about
reward
in terms of gnats you can talk about how
rewarding information is because
they're just some arbitrary carving up
of a single expression they expected
for energy that seems to me important
because that is if you like the sort of
in terms of a dimensional or unitary
unit analysis
that is a thing that truly does dissolve
the expiration exploitation
dilemma and puts the value of
information alongside the value of
a money or the value of a fruit
drop if you're doing animal experiments
so absolutely not you really want to
totally avoid any temptation to start
adding ad hoc
hyper parameters like temperature to
this beautiful construct
which explains everything the other
answer is absolutely yes
that in order to in order to
acknowledge that if you're just trying
to explain
the necessary properties dynamics
of systems that self-organize to some
non-equilibrium steady state
you are saying nothing about the nature
of that city state other than it is at
steady state so it could be very high
entropy steady state it could be very
low entropy
steady state it could be very hot it
could be very cold
you haven't really committed to any kind
of
steady state which means that
it's slightly disingenuous to say that
the imperative for everything is to
minimize
say a free energy functional it's not
that's why very carefully said
hamilton's principles stationary action
is just keeping it flat
at steady state it could be very high it
could be very low
and that starts to beg the question what
kinds of steady states are
non-equilibrium
are we really interested in simulating
reproducing describing
and if you get behi under the hood in
terms of
the relative entropies and the mutual
informations that
shape these steady states and in
particular the
the distributions over this markovian
partition into inside and outside the
blanket states
it turns out that one important
attribute or description of the state
depends upon the way in which the active
states increase
mutual information between the internal
and the external
and if you parameterize up with a
particular parameter and we'll call it
alpha
as a not to your question then suddenly
you really do need this alpha and this
alpha gets
in exactly as you say as a knob
on the expected complexity versus the
expected accuracy
or ambiguity so what that means is in a
more general formulation of the
of the free energy principle or
certainly its application to
understanding active inference
there would be this extra parameter that
really tells you you're dealing with
systems that are
exquisitely structured in the sense that
they are
they occupy a very small number of
states they could occupy
in a particular way that is active that
they actively construct
their mutual information between the
inside and the outside
at the moment that's not in the
literature so there are ongoing debates
amongst the younger people who love the
maths of this about
whether we just need a generic kale
divergence
or whether we need to exclude bits to
get to expected free energy
in by acknowledging there are different
kinds of non-equilibrium steady states
and in so doing you have to really think
about the relative importance for this
steady state
of technically the risk and the
ambiguity and the sensory entropy
so that's again that's a bit of an open
question which i'm hoping will be
resolving about a year's time
at which point your alpha will occur and
i'll try to call it alpha in your honor
awesome
maybe i should have gone with omega that
way it's the last parameter we ever need
but thank you appreciate it
absolutely fascinating there's been a
lot of emphasis on a single
all-encompassing learning principle this
grand unified theory of the brain
or indeed any system now um i've been
speaking to one of our friends on the
show
he's given us two questions this guy is
dr hari valpola he's an applied
theoretical neuroscientist and he's the
ceo of curious ai which is a
reinforcement learning based startup and
he's a very accomplished scientist
actually and and he says
it does make sense to claim that there's
a unified cortical
algorithm and anatomically the cortex is
very uniform and although there are
adaptations to specific
tasks they seem to be variations of a
single unified template and in biology
function follows form however he says
that to claim that everything follows
from free energy minimization is just
overly simplistic in his view he says
it's
obvious that for the core text
goal-orientated learning
and perception is crucially important he
says the cortex isn't just learning
and perceiving all the structure and
information it receives from the senses
learning is heavily modulated by task
demand and attention
and so is perception itself so he gives
this example he says
if you take a young child around nine
months old
the critical period for learning the
phonemes of your mother tongue and you
play some speech from the radio
the result is nothing but if you play
the same speech during a social
interaction
the child will learn to discriminate the
phonemes in the speech
i think it's an excellent observation
and it takes us into
a sort of world which we haven't really
been discussing so far which is
the different flavors of free energy
minimization and how it might be
manifest
and so just coming back to the point
that structure matters
structures of the brain being very
finely attuned to and
adapted to the context in which they're
that they're making their
inferences one would normally cast that
in terms of structure learning if i was
a statistician
there are at least three if not four
levels
of maximizing model evidence i.e
minimizing variational free energy
also known as marginal likelihood i can
make inferences to reduce my
uncertainty about states that change
with time
i can do learning which is reducing
uncertainty
or increasing the marginal likelihood
of the parameters of my generative model
i could also think about the hyper
parameters that encode
that usually cast in terms of precision
or neg entropy
of various distributions and that
interestingly
and speaks to ignoring things that we're
talking about previously with conor
sometimes it's
best to ignore in a base optimal sense
if you've got very inconsistent and
compatible information
that's you know one base optimal
explanation for ignoring and that speaks
to sort of
intermediate temporal scale of free
energy minimization
but the one i want to get to beyond that
is structure learning also known as
bayesian model selection
so if i was a statistician i wanted to
score the quality
of my generative model my hypothesis my
convolution model whatever it was then i
would
score it with a free energy
approximation or bound
on the marginal likelihood of the model
evidence now take another model another
hypothesis and i would
compare the adequacy of these two
hypotheses
using procedural bayesian model
comparison and
that is formally identical to choosing
the hypothesis
with the least free energy so the free
energy
scoring the evidence for this hypothesis
of that hypothesis
so you have now a mathematical
description
of what in cognitive signs would be
known
as structure learning optimizing the
very structure of your model
does it have three layers
as my deep network fit for purpose
should i
add another layer how many units do i
have in each layer do i have a more
sparse connectivity do i use
linear rectifying all of these
structural aspects
can in principle be evaluated in terms
of the the free energy or the marginal
of the underlying marginal likelihood or
the evidence
so you have this world of structure
learning now that world itself
can proceed at different time skills it
can proceed
in terms of the development of a
particular architecture
or phenotype if you're a developmental
psychologist
you would understand this structure
learning from a neurodevelopmental point
of view
as the brain grows experience dependent
learning
that is driven or can be at least
described by
free energy minimization or
self-evidencing or maximizing model
evidence
increa increasing through the addition
of different connections
different cortical layers and cortical
areas or bringing them online
through changes in connectivity that can
actually progress
right through until the early 20s in
your development
you would see that or you could describe
that in terms of structure learning
over somatic time but the exactly the
same principles apply at an evolutionary
time scale
so this notion of free energy
minimization as bayesian model selection
speaks to a simple understanding of
evolution
or as nature's way of doing natural
bayesian model selection i.e natural
selection
where you operationally associate the
adaptive fitness with the probability
this phenotype
exists which is just the evidence that
it is there the probability of
finding that phenotype in place and i
should also
say that all of these different
expressions of free energy minimization
at different spatial and temporal
scales are all exactly consistent with
some of the fundamental cybernetics and
inception of theories of
self-organization such as for example
the
regulator theorem you know that it is on
some reading provably true
that for any system or agent to regulate
its environment it has to embody or be a
good model
of that environment what does that mean
its structure must somehow
recapitulate the structure of the
environment generating
that it has to control or it has to
engage with
so what does that tell you it tells you
that the structure
including all those canonical micro
circuits including
those visual hierarchies of our brains
for example or the multiple hierarchical
layers in a deep neural network
have to be there if it is the case
that the world that they're trying to
model
has a deep structure if things are
hierarchically generated
and we know that the case for us because
most of our world is caused by
other creatures like us as we're
currently witnessing
so we know that there is that there is a
hierarchical and dynamical aspect to it
where
the hierarchy say interpersonal
interactions transcends just
individuals but also groups of people
con specifics families societies
political affiliations
theological affiliations or geographical
hierarchical structure
so it is hardly unsurprising that
the delicate deep hierarchically
structured
connectivity we find in a brain and in a
variation auto encoder
is a natural thing that has emerged from
the evolution of these architectures
that all
are conforming with the principle of
free energy minimization
it really resonates with a lot of the
things that we've been speaking about on
on our podcast here because in machine
learning we of course
there are inductive priors built into
models even the neural network has this
kind of hierarchical organization
which is an inductive prior but we've
spoken a lot about meta learning as well
when
this thing that you're saying that
there's a structurally relevant
inductive pathway which could be learned
but the last question from hari
is he wants to know about the cerebellum
for example he said there's plenty of
evidence that it learns by
supervised learning and can perfectly
well handle regulation tasks without any
models
and he cites innate reflexes which train
a complex feed-forward controller
without any internal models i mean
as a bit of a side thing here that
valpolo is is in a way implying that
the free energy principle is is kind of
unsupervised that's the way he's talking
about which there might be some truth to
that but we'll come back to that
but he also cites the basal ganglia the
hippocampus the amygdala and the
superior
caliculus each of them learns and their
learning algorithms definitely don't
seem to have much to do with the free
energy minimization in his opinion
and he says that the basal ganglia is a
kind of reinforcement learning and the
hippocampus is a one-shot learning
and the amygdala and the superior
caliculus are supervised learning for
specific tasks
and this is super interesting right
because he cites kahneman system 1 and
system 2 of thinking
there's this famous test where if you
give monkeys a sequence of cards with a
hidden pattern on
which need to be classified into two
classes humans
suddenly click they see the hidden rule
because their system two kicks in
and they start getting a hundred percent
accuracy very quickly but you don't see
that
with monkeys so valpolo was saying that
he doesn't see how that phenomenon could
be explained by the free energy
principle
right again a whole raft of really
interesting points there
all of those things can be explained by
the free energy principle and indeed
there's a small literature on all of
those things
if people are interested you can get
into the literature i have to say
because the literature may not be
the familiar literature for people in
machine learning it's really
he's asking some fundamental questions
about functional anatomy
and probably more specifically the
computational anatomy that we can
ascribe to various structures and
hierarchies
and connectomes in the brain so for
example
recent thinking about the cerebellum is
that it plays the role
of actually a supervisor so it may well
be the case that the cerebellum plays a
role in the amortization
of carefully acquired skilled
movements that become increasingly
skilled
as the cerebellum watches the cortex and
in particular the pre-motor cortex
supplementary motor area and the motor
cortex per se
hierarchically exchange messages all
prescribing those predictions for that
reflexive kind of predictive coding
we're talking
about before that are delivered to the
spinal cord and the
motor reflex arcs but of course that
sort of
low level description of motor control
does rest upon this one deeply
structured and informed
hierarchy of predicting what am i going
to do next because the cerebellum can
watch that
it can watch the cortex learning how to
compose
particular movements and if it can
therefore
learn how to do that then it can
amortize it so i miss i'm assuming that
we all know what amortization is
um but what i what i mean here is that
we can
offset or defer the cost of the bayesian
belief updating
that we've talked about before is
entails a computational complexity and
therefore also a thermodynamic cost
by actually hardwiring and learning the
mappings
from certain beliefs to certain sort of
predictions say that drive
murder reflexes in that sense the
cerebellum
can i think be very usefully understood
in terms of being involved in supervised
learning but i'd actually turn it on its
head
and basically say it's been supervised
by the cortex but in a way that allows
the cerebellum
to tell the cortex well normally you do
it like that why don't you just do it
quickly
and efficiently and bake in those
mappings
without having to worry about the the
actual belief updating and converging to
dynamically on a gradient flow to
converging to a free energy minimum
and that story i think can also be used
to explain the particular role
of say the dorsal and ventral striatum
and the basal ganglia
in arbitrating between whether we do a
sort of system one versus a system
do we think about stuff do we do our
belief updating and a bit of
planning as inference or do we just do
what we've always done
habitually respond quickly and
efficiently by
harnessing something that has already
been amortized
and that i think is a really interesting
interpretation of habitation
versus deliberative thinking which from
the point of view
of a neuroscientist would be the
equivalent of system one versus versus
system two
in that sort of edge between machine
learning and reinforcement learning
sometimes
referred to as model free versus model
based and
i would not subscribe to that in the
sense that the
the habit has to be learned from the the
good old-fashioned belief updating and
learning
you can't you're not given habits you're
given reflexes but to learn a habit
to learn this is the kind of thing that
i usually do in this situation
and if i just do it i can dispense with
the computational cost
thereby minimizing the path integral
free energy by doing the habit
i noticed that slipped in there that
because it's a
principle of least action that entails a
path integral
so the amount of time it takes to
minimize your free energy
or get to your conclusion matters which
means you have to do it quickly
to minimize the action you've got to do
it quickly which means there's a natural
pressure
to habitize and amortize in the service
of minimizing free energy and i could go
on
in terms of telling you what i know
about the functional anatomy of the
amygdala
but perhaps it's best just to say that
there's a glorious game to be played
here in fact
it's the bread and butter of a jobbing
neuroscientist
sonya systems neuroscientist to
understand
the computational architectures and the
nature of
message passing implied by
either belief updating or predictive
coding or variational message passing
how it is enacted physiologically on a
neuroanatomy
that has a deep structure so this is our
job and it really started scratching the
surface in the past decades with
brain imaging and other tools at our
disposal
this is a very machine learning bias i'm
not sure if you're familiar with this
recently there has been a paper that
says that predictive coding
can approximate back propagation in
arbitrary graphs
do you have any take on this yes it is
i'm sure a friend of mine has
contributed to that yeah yes no
absolutely
by coincidence i think we're having a an
eurips
workshop on saturday that sort of
affords different perspectives on
backprop
i have to say from my perspective that's
completely
unsurprising and if there's any sense
that prop has been demeaned as something
which is not
that's really central to everything then
i think that's probably wrong
so from my it is
invariably the case that the
gradients with respect to anything of
variation free energy
can be written down as an a prediction
error
which means that if you believe that the
universe of
interesting things that basically
is performing a gradient flow on
a variational free energy functional
then you also believe
that they are via the chain rule
minimizing their prediction error
so it's for me backprop is just if you
like a
a nice linearized chain rule-esque way
statement of things that work
flow on free energy gradients that can
always be written down
with the back propagation of prediction
errors it doesn't surprise me the slight
is that predictive coding
belongs to this class of algorithm as
does propagation of errors
and i would actually submit everything
that works
should be should be described in along
those lines
i think that's one of the first times
i've heard neuroscientists actually say
something positive about backprop
so that's really fascinating so i have a
second question and that is
in your own personal opinion what has
been the most interesting progress in
systems neuroscience you've seen since
you first proposed the free energy
principle whether it's directly related
to it or not
standing back from a non-personal point
of view
the whole pragmatic term towards
embodiment
we've seen in the 10th century in
cognitive science has really been
a very big thing that has been
underwritten and also
has been lent momentum by theoreticians
like ourselves
within that the role of predictive
processing that's become a meme now
so you can't write a paper in cognitive
neuroscience now without
a nod to predictive processing at some
level
of an inactive and embodied situated
contextualized
sword so that's been a slow
and really important shift which is
presenting all sorts of really
interesting
issues in terms of exciting developments
in the neurosciences an increasing
quest for understanding the nature
of these epistemic affordances which
drive us in particularly in terms of
social neuroscience echo niche
construction
communication with others and how we
forage for information you know
that seems to be in the context of
usually social interactions
also touching upon an understanding of
feelings and emotion
and how resolving uncertainty about
bodily states
in my world that will be interceptive
inference gets into this game as an
integral part of these deep hierarchical
models that try to explain everything
what role do literally gut feelings have
in my
propositional beliefs about where i am
or who i am and how i should be behaving
so challenging questions that are now
starting to address
key aspects of intelligence
from the point of view of neuroscience
such as the emergence of selfhood and
what underpins it
and self in relation to others so we're
now talking about
cultural economic construction and
multi-agent interactions
so that's been very exciting
so i guess maybe to end the show i'd
like to ask you on
potentially a controversial question i
don't know i've been trying to find your
official answer on this and i haven't
been able to find it but
if we take for granted that the free
energy principle
explains a great deal about how certain
systems
of the kind we've been elucidating will
function
does it explain the origin of those
systems
so does the free energy principle for
example
have anything to say about abiogenesis
on earth on the origin of life on earth
that first spark
that created systems which can then
follow a trajectory
guided by the free energy principle or
is that outside of its scope
i'm sorry to add on a deflationary
though but i'm afraid it's outside of
its scope
i say that sort of in in a rigorous way
because remember
all of the interesting math and all this
sort of
physics of sentience all this bayesian
mechanics
all inherits from the assumption of a
non-equilibrium steady state
that entails a markov blanket as such
where it's only about steady states it's
not where that steady state came from
so there's lots of there are lots of
really interesting questions
there's a great paper by kate jeffries
and there's lots of work by
people at los alamos around the world
trying to say is it almost unavoidable
that we will end up with these deeply
structured
delicate mock-off-blanketed systems
that become increasingly rich and have
longer longer information lengths and
more itinerant dynamics
as the universe unfolds it would be
great to know the answer to that
and to have a tractable mathematical
formulation of that
i'm afraid that the free energy
principle in its vanilla form as it
currently stands
does not give you that no all it says is
if that thing has evolved
this is the property these are the
properties that it must possess
but at least it can tell us we should
continue exploring and looking around to
address that
uncertainty yes clever yes of course
some better better free energy principle
professor fristen thank you very much
for joining us this evening it's been an
absolute honor to have you on the show
wonderful talking to you thank you very
much indeed
thank you so much thank you truly a
pleasure
thank you very much they're very
informed questions i got a sense you
knew the answers before you asked them
but
that's how i felt
i'm going to be honest with you after
talking to him myself
i think he has a very intuitive
understanding of very deep topics
and a massive depth of knowledge and
therefore when he tries to communicate
that
i think he just what's the right way to
say this
he leaves behind a trail that's a little
bit hard for us to follow because he's
just moving at a very
kind of deep and fast rate in my opinion
he was trying to help us
understand just operate on such a high
level
that it's not always easy to follow tell
them that that's just the result of
externalized intelligence
oh bad you might get your alpha constant
i would have called it something like
kappa after my first name
alpha's good i mean start with the first
one like why why do we need to go
that's good it's the maximally ambiguous
answer that still fits the data
yeah yeah i when i at this hedge fund i
worked out we had a problem one day and
lost a couple million dollars or
something not me personally but the fun
and we we called up one of the guys who
maintains our market data feeds
and we're like so was the ticker that
had the problem today
the nasdaq ticker or the nicey ticker
and he goes yes
we're like uh it's not a yes or no
question so that was kind of an answer
like from from person there it's like do
we need alpha
you know no and yes
no anyway we really hope you've enjoyed
the episode today we've had so much fun
making it
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments and we'll
see you back
next week